welcome to another one of my
sadler's stories you can tell i have a
little companion here this is
sassy also known as sassy pants also
known as minou
also known as a number of other things
as well
and she is a 17 going on 18 year old cat
who i've known now for
over 10 years and she
was one of two kittens that was fostered
as rescues by
my my wife they were survivors of a fire
in new york she's not big on being on
camera somehow she always knows
that's the case so i'm going to let her
down in just a sec
but first i thought i would have her
here for just a minute
and she and i as i tell her sometimes
when we're going over
our story together became friends first
meaning
that of all the animals that my wife had
sassy was the one who i first
held and talked to and petted and picked
up
and the story goes sort of like this
so i'll tell the the story of how my my
wife and i
got together in much greater detail at
some other point but
suffice it to say we knew each other
from
high school and had crossed paths in the
1990s
and then later on reconnected and
fell in love and eventually decided
since i was living in north carolina and
she was living in new york that i would
leave my position at fayetteville state
university and move
up there prior to that we were doing the
commuter couple thing which meant that i
would drive
from fayetteville north carolina all the
way up to the hudson valley
in new york which under good conditions
would be about a
14 hour drive uh with a few stops
uh mostly up 95 and
took quite a while but you know towards
the end of
the trip you'd start getting a little
bit um
punch drunk and you know a little
reaction slowed
so the first time that i i came
up i drove up and we
met together and the next day we went to
my wife's apartment later on would be
our apartment
it was what was euphemistically called
the carriage house apartment which
basically means an apartment above a
garage
so quite small as a matter of fact i'll
tell a story about that sometime or
maybe i'll get her out and we'll talk
about it together because
cramped conditions and in that apartment
um she had the two dogs that she'd also
rescued and these these two cats
and by that time sassy and teensy
her sister you know were no longer
kittens they
they were full adult cats they each had
their own personality
teensy was actually a little bit bigger
than sassy sassy
had had a rough time of it at the start
a tail that went necrotic my my wife had
to give her antibiotics
for years and there there was not a good
prognosis for her but they both had
strong spirit and and made it through
and
so when i my my wife wanted to
introduce me to the dogs gradually but
the cats were in the apartment
when we went up the stairs and went in
and
teensy was always rather timid it took
her a while to
get used to people and you know i think
she may have peeked her head out
once and that was about it but sassy
came trotting out
and uh you know i said to her run around
and she came right over and i
picked her up and held her in my arms
and she started purring and
and we became friends at that point and
you know teensy came around eventually
um
she unfortunately didn't didn't live as
long as sassy she
she's been gone about six years
um some organ failures which
sometimes happens in cats and she and
sassy would you know lay
together and play together you may have
seen some some of the pictures in social
media
or when i uh posted some of the things
about the cats and the dogs they all
were one
big pack which didn't mean that they
always got along
but they they certainly stuck up for
each other and
looked out for each other and they would
cuddle up
uh quite often as well and they did so
with with me
some of you may have seen pictures of
the cats helping me read helping
very euphemistically since often they
would like pull the pages down or
lay on top of my books those view of
cats know how prone they are to doing
that
apparently they used to play on my
wife's keyboard
quite a bit as well and i think at one
point sent an email message
by mistake sassy has now come back in
the room she's over in her
beds and uh getting hunkered down
so sassy and i have been through a lot
together and i thought i would you know
talk about
her story and the time that we've spent
together and some of the things that
have happened and some of the things
that we did and that it would be kind of
kind of enjoyable for for all of you so
one of the things that i'll tell you
about
that we we did in kingston when we lived
in in new york in the hudson valley was
she would get to go outside and
actually i would let both the cats
outside but teensy didn't want to spend
any time
outside so that wasn't much of an issue
and
sassy was originally kind of nervous
about it we had a fenced in yard
although the fence actually went into
the woods
and part of it was not you know very
rigid fence it was
a wire fence and she could get on both
sides of it
so i began by taking her downstairs i
would work outside
quite often reading or working on my
computer
and i would i would carry her down with
me and she'd struggle a little bit
and then we'd we'd go out and i'd put
her next to me by the table and then
she'd slink away
trying to get to the staircase and then
run right up the stairs and go back
inside
if the door was closed obviously she
pawed it and and make some
you know she didn't really make a lot of
sounds but sometimes she would make
sounds
in that case as a matter of fact she's
only become a very vocal cat in the last
few years and so gradually she became
used to being outside i think it helped
that she saw the dogs
who you know she was good friends with
hanging out outside
and she would you know come down
i would leave the door open sometimes
and she would she would poke her head
out and then she would come down to see
what i was doing
she'd wander over by the dogs eventually
she went around the whole yard
and that's when she started to get
herself in a little bit
of trouble
sometimes you know once she realized
that she could go out outside she really
enjoyed it
and sometimes she would sneak outside
and i would sometimes come home from
work
and find her crying because she had gone
up the hill and had managed to get on
the other side of the fence
and then couldn't figure out how to get
herself back in and get herself
back to her her home so she'd cry for me
and then i would have to climb up the
hill uh and
and as best as i could some of it was
you know falling the
dirt would fall down and all that and
then i'd put her on my back
and she'd sink her claws in and then i
would climb back down
and take her around the yard and we'd
come back up and she'd be
secure now for a little while
and you know we did this a number of
times
the she you know i don't think she ever
really figured out how to get
from one side of the fence it was easy
to get out of the fence
she could never figure out how to get
herself back in or maybe she did
and and i just never realized it because
she didn't panic at that point anymore
so that was you know a good part of what
we did and of course we did a lot of
snuggling up and
and you know playing you know she was a
very playful cat as was her sister
she loves catnip now in her her
late adult life she gets catnip whenever
she wants to and i also go and
pick wild catnip on my on my walk so
she's kind of in catnip heaven
she'll actually cry for it in the
morning if she doesn't get it
one of the other big things that
happened with her was
we took a cross-country trip together
and it's not the first time that she'd
ever
been in a car obviously she had to go to
the vet and she
and her sister and the dogs
took you know cross-country trips out
here to
wisconsin with my wife previously as
well
but this was when we were moving and
we were packed everything up into a
giant u-haul much bigger truck than we
actually needed a truck that eventually
broke
down in the middle of pennsylvania
after you know going quite slow for
for quite a while and so she was in this
this wire cage
my wife drove one of our our
subarus and we'd had the other one
already out in in wisconsin
loaded up had the dogs in there and i
had the big truck
and sassy in the cage next to me and she
was not super happy about
being in a cage to begin with um she you
know she had
food and drink and and you know some
some catnip
and lots and lots of nice things to lay
down on
but she cried for a good way you know
the sort of wow
kind of meowing that shows that they're
in a bit of distress they're not super
happy about what's going
on but after a while she calmed down
she'd look out the window
and we'd drive along and and so um
you know things went pretty good until
the truck
started having uh problems we we you
know
the um def fluid that was the issue with
that i've done another video about that
that trip that you can watch if you want
to
and we eventually had to get towed
the truck broke down we had to put sassy
along with me in the cab of the semi tow
truck
and ride another hour and a half to i
think it was youngstown
uh it was our halfway point and then in
the middle of the night
you know load one truck into another
truck
to replace it and then the next day
there goes sassy back in the cage
back with me driving in a smaller truck
now to here in wisconsin where then
andy's parents uh met us and we stayed
in a hotel
and sassy got to you know explore the
hotel room and
and all that while the dogs did as well
and it was nice to be back in
in wisconsin again where were where my
wife and i are both from
obviously the dogs and cats were not not
from wisconsin
but this became their their new home and
then you know we got to move
into this much larger apartment with
lots of places for sassy to explore
uh at that time the dogs were still able
to go up and down the stairs and
and so you know it was nice to have the
extra space
and that was more or less the end of
sassy's outside escapades until fairly
recently
when we thought you know we had taken
her to the vet
and uh she was recently was having some
issues with with a bit of
you know too much weight loss she's got
her weight back on now fortunately
um and so we went to the vet for one of
the checkups and then we
thought about well should we you know go
and and uh
see uh andy's mom and and so we did
and then we were like well maybe we say
maybe sassy could go outside and so
we let her outside in the yard and as
usual she was kind of scared
at first kind of nervous she actually
wanted to head under the car
and i knew she was going to do that so i
headed her off and then she realized
holy crap i'm outside i can do all this
stuff there's all these smells all these
sites all this stuff that i don't get
exposed to
normally and then it was game on and she
really
enjoyed herself i even took her
in a more recent trip over to the wood
pile where there's like some logs that
were cut a while back and she gets on
top of them and starts scratching and
asserting herself she even spent some
time just like laying down in the yard
watching things going on so she enjoyed
that quite a bit
and for a 17 year old cat
she is in pretty good shape especially
for a 17 year old cat who had some
serious health problems
early on in her life
she goes up and down the stairs when she
wants to she hops up on things
she eats pretty well and
we do have her on some some medications
that that help her out with her
you know arthritis and things but you
know imagine
in in cat ears she's basically the
equivalent of an 80 or 90 year old woman
so she's doing a pretty good job and
she's
she's really quite you know i've had a
lot of cats in my life
and you know sassy is the one who i
i still have left we have a very close
relationship she uh she likes to sleep
next to me
a lot of the time and then of course
when she she's had enough of that she
gets up and comes back down here
and uh you know the day is is kind of
punctuated particularly in these covid
times where none of us are going
anywhere
i think she really enjoys having people
around non-stop the only time i'm i'm
out of here is to
you know maybe do an errand or to take a
walk
and so she's she's you know used to
us having a constant presence in the
apartment and being able to come out and
talk to us if she wants to and get up in
her lap occasionally
or lay down in front of us we we have
you know some toys for her as as usual
of course the
the cat toys that people buy she's
totally uninterested in
but there's quite a few other things one
of the
the things that we did is we bought a
big thing of of uh
paper towels from costco on these giant
sort of like industrial sized rolls
turns out those rolls are one of the
best toy for her she loves it
you know they kind of cut they come
apart a little bit so they look like a
spring made out of cardboard
and she'll knock them over if we set
them up and rub herself
on them and squeeze her face into it
there's there's a few other things that
she really enjoys the rings off of
certain
uh bottled water drinks you know you
roll those on the floor and she
goes crazy chasing them obviously string
you know and catnip uh the you know
catnip is in the mint family so you get
these long
squares stems after she's pulled all the
leaves off and
she really enjoys that she even uh you
know
still enjoys doing a little bit of fetch
when i didn't get to see this but when
she was younger
she had a hacky sack that you could
throw and she'd bring it back to you
and and you know fetch it so she still
does a little bit of that with the ring
you know she'll bring it to you and spit
it out because she wants you to play
with her but
she's you know she's an old cat so she
doesn't do that for an
awful lot she spends a lot of time
sleeping which is which is great
she does enjoy hanging out and cuddling
and so so she's the last of our animals
who who has left
the end of our four-legged family our
pack and
we're happy that we still have her maybe
we'll get to enjoy her for
several more years and we're cherishing
the time that we have with her so i
thought i would um
do a little bit telling you stories
about
sassy and some of the things we've done
together
and some of the time we've we've spent
together
you